I was having some trouble with the game.
And so I finally got it all set up.
And then I was scared it didn't work.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much for the podcast.
You guys, I realized I forgot something.
Last stream, my handy dandy whip.
So we have it.
And I thought, oh my gosh, I was like, wait, with the cowboy hat, with the hat and the braids.
And I look like a real cowgirl, no?
Oh, thank you so much for the tag gifted.
Space alien.
Thanks for the fun gifted.
Forgot my clothes?
Oh.
Thank you, Minta.
Yeah.
Hi, Smyr.
Thank you for the fun gifted.
Welcome back, everybody.
Um, I want to kind of just get into it because...
Uh, I...
I'm only 21% through the game!
No, um...
Confirm load, yes.
I...
Still need to finish the last...
Wait, where am I?
The last, the first movie!
The last chapter of the...
Of the first movie.
So we gotta do that.
Sorry if I miss some people.
Oh, no, thank you so much, Katsun Tecuh!
Thank you, thank you.
I can't, I can't like scroll through chat as I do usually in case I miss something.
So sorry!
I look like Applejack.
Don't I?
I look like if an Applejack...
We're a ghost girl.
And not a... a horse.
But a cat.
Ducky, thanks for the get there!
Um, but yeah, let's open the Ark, and then we will today do the Temple of Doom!
Yippee!
We have the birthday!
I know you can't sing for me, so can I get a hot dog instead?
Hot dog!
Happy hot dog!
So nothing like Applejack.
What are you talking about?
Oh my god, there's...
Who let this monkey in, though?
What the heck?
Why are you in here?
Okay, I have to remember how to destroy things.
I could never forget.
Wait, and then this is to...
Wait, I want to bring you in for a big old smooch.
Let's get some more money.
Like riding a bike.
Boop!
Whoa!
Why is there a monkey in the museum?
Sounds like a movie.
The monkey in the museum.
Who are you?
Wait, why do you have my hat?
Wait, are you me?
Wait, who are you?
What?
Are you me?
Oh my gosh, I thought this, my weeaboo-ass brain was just like, wow, a Miko.
Wait, is that me?
Turn around!
I can't...
Wait, no.
Who are you?
I'm Yuba with my coat off.
Alright, let's get into it, baby.
Opening the arc!
Story.
Ta-da-da!
Oh, that's it.
Oh, that's right.
They took Marion.
That's her name, right?
Oh, wait.
Is he looking at her in her underwear?
Wait, she looks really naked in this.
Wait, I'm blocking it?
But she looks like so naked.
Wow-wee.
You're just gonna walk around like that?
Okay.
Nice.
This is a kid's game.
Maybe.
Alright, I know I need to build back.
Oh, look at all those guys over there.
What's this?
I'm really destroying everything.
No fences allowed.
So guys, today I'm so relaxed.
You want to know why I'm so relaxed?
Ah!
Wait, they're not coming over.
Oh, that guy over there doesn't know what to do.
Wait, he's a little stuck.
Wait, can I sims them?
Sims them!
No!
Dang it.
Uh-oh.
Okay, um...
Yeah, a gun!
And he's shooting her!
Uh, what did I do for this?
That, okay.
I'm relaxed because I went with my mama and... Oh wait, that's the hat!
I need the hat.
And we went to a head spa so I might be a little extra dumb today because I'm all Like, mmm, head has been thoroughly scratched.
It was her first time going to one.
Oh, whoops.
No, I was trying to destroy this, but I guess we cannot.
That's fine.
So I take this out to here.
Okay.
Yeah, my brain is so squishy.
Did she just fall in?
She's fine.
Okay.
Build, build, build, build, build, build.
Nice.
I don't know why I'm sneaking.
Wait.
Oh!
Oh, oops.
Oh, wait.
Get up there.
Get up there, Indy.
Oh, there we go.
I have to hold it down.
So that's all I do.
A spa for your head?
Never heard of one.
It's not, well, it's like a head spa, but then also they have massages.
and you can get a facial too.
It's like everything sometimes.
Depends on the place, but it just...
It's so good.
I recommend everybody goes at least once in your life or afterlife.
So glad even the afterlife.
All my ectoplasm is so squishy now.
How do I get this?
Indiana Jones, learn how to swim.
Dive!
Oh, I got it!
Okay, cool.
All right, now we're here.
See where the baddies were though.
Can I destroy this?
Do-do-do!
Yes!
What is this?
A bigger gun?
We love to see it.
A gun or a bigger gun?
What's this?
More money?
More money, more problems.
Except in Lego Indiana Jones.
More money, more people.
That we can purchase for our museum.
It doesn't sound quite right.
Maybe.
Oh, oops.
I just instinctively destroy.
Am I supposed to...
Well, what's this one do?
Okay.
Hold?
Baby core, thank you!
Let's go back to the boat.
So I brought this here.
Just destroy everything.
Yeah?
Yeah.
is there what am i missing actually wait what's oops one moment okay wait here what was this did i try this thing no this moves that do i need to get up there somehow what do i put here
puzzle.
I think she's drowning.
Oh.
She's fine.
Her booty's out, though.
Man, put on a shirt.
Or some pants.
I mean...
I don't need to talk to this guy.
Oh, wait!
I am wearing... No, I'm not wearing the hat.
I don't think so.
Use the whip.
Oh, I do have a whip.
Oops.
All I know how to do is destroy.
I don't know how to love All I do, everything I love Everything I touch That I love Gets whipped What do I whip on?
Whip pick?
Oh, here maybe Aha!
Okay, okay Sorry, getting back into the swing of things The whip of things Oh, my money We need a tiny character Okay,
we need a tiny character Some puzzles can only be completed.
Oh, that's right!
I can!
I can do that!
I forgot!
Oh, wrong thing.
Stupid woman.
What are you doing?
Try using the case files.
Crawl through it, Mito.
Oh wait!
Okay, we inhabited- our soul is within the- what's this do?
Oh!
Pull!
Oh, okay.
We need to both pull at the same time.
You go to the other one.
Ma'am.
Ma'am, go to the other one.
There we go.
Um...
Do you think they're gonna notice?
That guy's got a gun.
Oh!
Oh, I think this needs to go to the ship.
Before I do that, I want to destroy their headquarters.
Yeah, they had a gun.
Okay.
This is mine now.
And I think we are stealing a boat.
Oh.
Oh my gosh, she's so smart!
She knew exactly what I needed.
Oh, wait.
Wait, is it why to use a thing?
Yeah, okay.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, too far.
Oh, okay.
Oops.
I don't know how to use it.
Do-do-do.
What is this?
Ah, oh.
Oops.
No, not down.
Wait.
Okay, almost one side.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm an aiming... Why are my hearts, like, silver?
Oh, I think that's the...
Maybe the machine I'm using.
Nice aim.
I'm a godgamer, baby.
Why did they build it like this?
Huh.
Curious.
Oh, I'm a true adventurer.
Move out of the way, Marion!
Uh-oh.
Don't drop.
There's gotta be something over here.
Oh!
Is this the way?
Or is this secret?
What is this?
We could even beat up boulders.
Indy's strength knows no bounds.
It's crazy.
This is the way.
Okay.
Uh-oh.
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
Yeah!
Kick his butt!
Hand kick this guy's butt.
Oh, my money.
Oh, wait.
We can get in that.
Alright, alright, alright.
So we're trying to open this up, maybe?
I hear more people, or I hear something.
Do I whip it here?
Yes, I- Oh!
Why did it explode?
Is this Half-Life 3?
Yeah.
Actually.
Oh my god!
Preemptive death?
Wait, I won on my money!
Sometimes I shoot on accident.
Sometimes I don't mean to shoot, and I just want to use my fists.
First, you know, whip it out.
No, no.
First, I whip it.
Whip it good.
I think that doesn't sound so good.
The first thing you said.
Oh, what's this?
Wait!
What is this?
Is this where I need a...
A shovel?
Not sure.
Wait, what's over here?
This looks like a puzzle.
How do we get over here?
Aw, curious.
Well, let's just keep going, I guess.
Oh!
A wrench.
Alright.
Oh, to fix the car.
Oh.
Yeah.
Oh wait, my god, my god, my...
God, no.
Marion!
We're fine.
We're not okay.
Okay, if we're...
We were not.
Where is she?
Do I need to unlock it?
Where'd she go?
And he doesn't need a gun.
He's got his fist.
I didn't get that hat from the guy, which is sad.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, we're just hiding, like a little goofball.
Destroy the street lamp!
Oh.
Or don't.
Okay.
I want this horse.
Nope.
Ride the horse.
Some animals throw you high into the air when you jump off of them.
Okay.
Wow!
You really did that!
Goldship!
Yeah.
Oh.
Okay, girl.
What the hell are you doing?
I didn't build this for you to just do nothing.
Excuse me.
Where were you?
Okay.
Indy, fix this.
No, fix it.
Fix it?
How do I fix it?
Oh, there it is.
And
then, what is this here?
Okay, we got so much going on around here.
I wish I could unlock...
Oh, maybe I bust it down.
Okay, here we go.
Oh.
Alright, watch out, Marion!
Wait!
Hello?
Oh, okay.
The very long hint.
Wait.
Get out.
There we go.
They're like, hey, you know, now you have a thing that's big enough, tall enough to jump on.
We're busting.
Eew.
I like how it explodes.
Wait.
Are we making this thing, this A tier?
Oops.
Okay, thank goodness.
Oh, don't do it again.
Okay, wait.
All right, so now here.
But how do I get more?
Looks like a four?
Kind of.
Wait, where do I get more from?
Oh, this?
Wait, how did that get over?
here wait who moved the truck um excuse me oh wait who moved the truck marion you have one job oh uh oh wait uh you know i was just about to compliment how easy it is to drive the car in this game compared to like other games sometimes oh shoot wait indy indy oh he did it okay all right we're fine Oh!
No!
Please!
Okay, now we push this.
No, no, push here.
Okay, that does that one.
Now we have... Like, we just need two more.
Hmm.
Just need two more.
Oh, maybe I stand on one and the Marion stands on the other.
Okay.
that?
Alright, Marion.
Oh, okay, Indy changed his mind.
He said, no.
I am the master of my fate.
I decide what I want to stand on.
Oh, it's a bazooka!
No, fire.
Yeah!
Is there anything else?
I don't want to quite go yet.
Is there anything else we can blow up?
What?
What is the horse?
See, there's this part too.
I wonder if we did this same pattern.
If this would open up, you know?
Let's try it.
So...
Bottom?
Okay.
Two and then up instead.
Okay, okay.
Let's try it.
She don't need no...
Yeah, she's a high jumper.
All right, so you pick it up.
Pick it up.
Okay.
It was...
It was like this one, right?
And then...
Oh, okay, Andy.
You got this.
Okay.
Nice.
And then this one.
No, no.
No, Mary.
Okay, yeah.
There we go.
I don't know why she did that What a stupid lady Yeah Yeah yeah yeah Yeah I'm so smart I'm genius Boats go binted
Uh Have no boat Yeah Yeah Two out of how many Did that say And then like what the heck is this Oh wait I wonder Oh wait I wonder if this is for this little guy.
Okay, never mind.
What if I blow this thing up?
Alright, time to blow stuff up.
No, no, no.
Take it out.
Why is it arched now?
Wait, can I blow up the other side?
Blow up more?
Wait, why is she can she destroy it?
her fists but i couldn't okay one more no no put oh
it was literally nothing it was actually nothing and we don't have a shovel unfortunately where i don't oh wait this too wait there we go indy grab the other side.
I guess if this is if you don't want to use the truck, you use the horses to get up there.
Why are they not grabbing on together, though?
Maybe because we already solved the puzzle, but in our own creative way.
We solved the puzzle in our own way.
Okay, let's keep going.
That's it!
Blow it up!
It's the Ark.
Wait, why?
Oh.
Oh, where'd that guy come from?
Up there.
He's sweaty.
A sweaty Lego man.
Do Legos even have pores?
Oh, my god!
Wait.
Oh, okay.
Are we gonna watch them Lego die from the Lego ghosts?
Oh, sorry, Indy.
Wait, am I giving him hearts again?
Sephiroth?
What is this?
Why is the music like this?
Oh.
Oh my god.
What is this?
Oh.
Um, let's build whatever the hell this is.
Or, oh my god, she's the strongest lady ever.
Hey, leave me alone.
Hi!
Leave me alone!
Thank God!
The music is insane!
Yeah, kill him!
Okay, now we have to build this thing, huh?
Oh yeah, I gotcha, I gotcha.
Alright.
And what did that do, actually?
Everybody's waiting their turn to get beat up.
Cool, I barely made that.
Okay, whoa, there's a lot going on here.
Yeah, let's stop the grenade, man.
How do we get up here?
Is it this?
Yes, maybe.
Okay, and we go over, and we're going over, and I'm going up.
Oh, I need you.
Indy, I need you!
Indy, boom!
Where'd Marion go?
Yeah!
Oh, we get one hit to him every time.
Oh, uh, where'd he go?
Oh, never mind.
Oh, he got one hit.
I got one hit by him.
Kill him!
Oh, we killed him!
The music is so crazy.
Oh no, close your Lego eyes!
There he is!
Oh my god!
They are Lego ghosts!
Oh no, he's Lego!
Oh no, he's Legoing out!
Oh, he's gonna Lego melt!
Wait, I want to see him Lego melt!
That'll be so sick!
Oh my god!
Imagine you play this game as a kid, but you've never seen the movie.
We didn't get to see it.
I like her Lego cleavage.
One Lego ghost laughed.
It's me.
I almost said Lego.
Level complete!
Yippee!
Marion Nightgown.
You've done that before!
Oh,
a nice brick.
Woohoo!
Okay, we finished up Covenant of the Ark!
Time for the temple.
Oh, the temple of Doom soon.
I don't remember.
Why is she not like them hugging?
What's wrong?
Oh.
Oh, oh.
Oh, Indy.
Ah!
Oh, they sealed the arc away.
That's right.
Marion, NSFW.
No!
Did I forget something?
So many mysteries in here.
What if you're trying to find something?
Wait, how's that guy doing that?
Literally, Scooby-Doo.
Wait, are these...
From a movie?
Lost forever.
Oh, wait, they're concept!
This is so cute!
They'll find it eventually.
I'm sure.
I don't think they ever want them to come out.
That's true.
Okay, how do I get out of here?
Thank you.
What's...
It's so ominous.
24.1%.
Lego YouTubers.
What's happening?
Oh.
Oh, what is going on?
Ah.
Look at that little picture.
Yay!
She's all dressed up just for me, baby.
Let me see that booty.
Booty, booty, booty.
Wow, she really just got nothing on in the back.
Wow.
Hey!
Hands off of her!
Ha-ha!
Okay.
Shall we?
Let's go buy a couple more guys, and then we'll start the next game.
Wait.
Was it this one?
Or this one?
What is this one?
Yeah.
Oh.
Wait, these are the ones I got.
Okay, okay, okay.
I was like, wait a second.
Who have I?
Locked.
Monkey Man.
You're mine.
I can't buy it.
Indiana Jones Desert Disguise, you're mine.
I can't buy anyone else.
Oh, wait.
No, I can't.
Capitan, you're mine.
Let's go adventure.
full of doom
was she gonna sing anything goes oh
it's like simlish but like lego language instead actual noises
Oh my god, it was poison!
Oh no, I also drank it too!
I'm so stupid!
Oh my god, I'm dying?
Wait.
Oh, I can't do anything!
I gotta release the balloons!
Throw items to get it to destroy.
them.
Oh my god, he can't even hop.
Okay, we're just gonna have to do everything.
Wait, wait, no, no, no!
Oh no!
Okay, no, just kidding.
Dangos!
This is so cute.
Oh, oh, ah, ah.
Push, push this way.
Push, push, push, push, push, push, push.
Push, push.
Oh, I got him.
There we go.
I'm not quite sure if actually that was a right thing.
Oh, here.
Build a thing.
It says to throw stuff, but like...
I'm just gonna let Indy die at this rate.
Oh, you!
You need the blue antidote to secure him.
I know I'm trying!
What am I throwing, though?
Oh, here we go.
We're throwing this.
Throw it at him.
Ha ha!
Indy?
Wait, I can't switch to Indy.
Is this the antidote?
No.
Oh, wait.
Let's throw this.
Oh.
Pick it up.
Pick it up and throw.
There we go.
What do you do with it?
Where do you go?
Indy, you did?
Oh, I can switch to him now.
He's just hobbling along a little bit.
Oh, it's this?
Oh, it's another one.
Oh, I see.
Where did he throw it to, though?
Oh, I see, I see, I see.
Okay, now you throw this one to that guy.
Oh, no, no, that's not what I wanted to do.
Okay, pick that up and throw it.
Throw it to him.
Okay.
Where did it, where did they throw it to?
That guy, okay, we need to find another one?
This is so goofy.
It's in here.
How do we get it, though?
Don't mind me, Indy.
You'll survive until you...
Until you need to.
You're fine.
Let's see, maybe...
I built this, but I don't know for what reason.
Oh, maybe to hop up here and then...
Ah, so close!
Wait, I'm so close.
I also, there's the dragon here, but I don't think Indy can get on top of it.
I don't think he has the strength.
Alright, Indy.
Come on.
Come on, Indy.
You can do it.
Oh, wait, there's another one here.
Minky can't read.
What are you talking about?
I'm literally trying to do the stuff.
Okay, now that's...
Probably the dragon's the last one, right?
You didn't read the text.
What do you mean?
What text?
I didn't see text.
What, the text that's literally right there?
There's this one.
I think this is the last one.
What text?
Hold on.
What about him poison?
I could just stand here and scream?
A button
to push to scream.
There was a text that said, Oh, Willy's voice can shatter.
Oh, I didn't see that.
Ah!
That's why I scream.
There's, like, an actual reason to do so.
Drink it, drink it, drink it.
I thought the screaming was just for fun.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm going to...
Oh, okay.
That doesn't affect him at all.
Wait, okay, I think we need to go this way.
Indeed.
Oh, yeah, baby!
Oh.
We were so close to greatness.
We were so...
Why doesn't he not die?
What's happening?
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, we could dodge.
We're fine.
We'll dodge.
Maybe...
Oh.
Push!
Push it!
Oh.
I, uh...
Yes.
Wait.
Oh, we need to run behind it!
Okay, come here, come here.
We gotta get behind it.
Oh my god.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
But I'm not quite sure.
What's the point here?
Wait.
Do I have to get the sword again?
Come here.
Oh, wait.
What's this?
Oh.
Wait.
What was the...
Oh.
What were they...
What did they look at and we're laughing about?
Wait, what were they...
Oh, my God.
I'm him!
Short round!
Look how cute he is!
Little baby.
We need a feminine...
There we go.
Oh, okay, we need you to keep doing that.
Okay, miss?
Uh, no, no.
Uh, okay.
Wait.
You, you.
Do this.
Okay.
Okay, someone needs to get up there.
We need, um, where's the easiest way?
Oh, here?
Ah, okay, not you, though.
Indy, come here, come here.
You get up here.
Whose balloon is this?
Oh, oh, it's, I can't do this.
I need the thuggy character.
Childhood classic.
Could have missed stream.
Thanks for dropping by, though.
Thank you for the super chat.
Okay, here we go.
Alright, what does short round do, I wonder?
What's his little special skill?
Hold on, one moment.
I'm collecting money.
Of course, I missed the blue one.
Here we go.
Oh, jeez.
Okay, we have to get one more thing.
Is it on this side?
What's this?
No!
Wait!
Oh my god!
We finally have...
Oh, oh, oops.
Oh my god!
He's short!
He's so small!
He might be the shortest!
Wait, I'm not good at timing these!
Uh-huh!
Or I forgot it's not timing at all.
Holding it down.
Oh my god!
He's the most useful character!
Oops.
Okay.
He's a kid in the movie, Minto.
Um, no he's not.
He's short round.
Build.
He's also a genius.
Look at him!
He's an engineer!
Oh my god!
Look at him go!
Wow!
He's literally building a car!
At his age!
Uh-oh.
Oh!
Oh, uh-oh.
Yeah, uh-oh.
Let's get in the car.
Oh, we have to fix the car.
Don't shoot a kid, man.
Oh, I punched him on accident.
Grab that.
Anybody else in here?
Anybody else?
Oh, there's so much stuff here.
Wow, there's actually so much in this area.
we gotta get the wrench we gotta fix the car all right
wait can i blow up the bicycle oh i can ride the bicycle choo choo coming true
i was building lego cars at his age too i was building lego castle We are not the same.
I don't know what to tell you, man.
You might be thinking, I'm a secret genius, but...
Oh, I'm just leaving.
Okay, bye bye!
Oh, uh...
Hello!
I hope we don't get- Oh no!
God!
We doing donuts!
Oh god!
Okay, we're fine.
Where did they actually come from?
Okay.
Alright, let's do things.
You.
Not you.
Our little lady.
I like how in the movie she's like so...
Like, not wanting to work with them about doing anything?
She doesn't want to work with them at all, but in this she's like totally...
Oh!
Oh my gosh, we just built a little hole!
Okay, cool.
Yeah, she's useless in the movie and in this she's like actually an engineer and building and contributing to society.
How can I grab that?
Whoa.
Wait, maybe I...
I'm not as short as I think I am.
Wait, what if I put this like here?
Okay, I'm cooking, I'm cooking.
Oh, I'm drifting.
Why am I doing that?
Why does he do that?
Why is he doing that, actually?
Wait, what?
What's happening?
Depth perception.
Is it my depth perception?
I can't tell.
I wish I could change the camera angle.
I don't think I can stand.
on it.
Dang, I really had a good thing going, I think.
Alright, somebody else take this.
Indy, you take it.
Why can't I stand on it?
Why can't I, why not?
And we're also, like, having to fix this plane ourselves.
What is this?
Oh, a forklift.
I am not certified.
Maybe Maybe I should get Forklift certified on stream.
Oh, oops.
Is Indy certified?
It's Indiana Jones!
He's gotta be!
Oh, oh my gosh.
So sorry, everybody.
My depth perception strikes again.
What?
Wait, how?
Maybe we drew this.
out of the way oh wait this is not a vehicle this is wait ah here we go wait
okay stay up there oh come on it doesn't stay up though let's try let's try what's her name
i don't think teamwork will help here i'm not quite sure Okay, this is fine.
Oh, I need Indy here.
Oh, no.
Oh, it does have to be Indiana Jones.
Okay, hold on.
If I use the forklift, I...
Oh!
Wait, he jumped on top!
And, um...
Uh...
Yes, sir.
Where do you want to go?
Wait, wait.
Huh?
Where did he go?
Indy?
Uh, let's see.
Alright, hold on.
Is there anything over here?
Let me just text.
Ow!
Ah!
Ouch!
Um, I was just...
I didn't put your gun away, please!
I...
I accidentally I accidentally killed myself trying to beat this thing up, which I guess you can't do?
It's the box that kills you.
Actually, why would they put it next to the box that doesn't kill you then?
That's really misleading.
And very unfair.
As a forklift operator who's currently at work, you're certified!
Oh!
I'm certified, I'm certified!
Okay, let's see.
I wish, though, Indy...
Okay, maybe what we do is this.
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
And then we lift up, and then we switch to Indy.
Okay, I don't think that's what we do.
Alright, lift.
Okay.
Yeah.
Um...
Oh!
I gamed, I gamed it, I gamed it!
I'm a gamer.
Mmm, mmm, mmm, mmm, mmm, mmm.
Minto gaming, me- Minto gaming, meinto gaming.
Alright, let's build whatever this thing is.
Anything goes.
Oh.
Alright, I think we need that.
I think that's pretty necessary.
Wait, but this isn't how the movie goes?
Wait,
this actually isn't how the movie goes, because they get into, like, that freight train, or train, oh, the plane.
And then, whip the engine.
Wait, oh, I think I get on here and do it.
Okay,
how do I get up here, though?
Oh, I think we gotta do the same thing with the forklift.
We can jump on the car.
Might be a little easier.
I can jump on the car, right?
Wait, where is he going?
Wait!
What are you doing, kid?
Stop!
He's sabotaging the mission!
I don't think actually I can jump on this car.
Wait, why not?
That's mysterious.
Why?
I wonder.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Get out of the car.
There we go.
Okay.
Yeah, I think we need to lift again.
Oh, he did it himself.
Nice.
He actually was useful.
Ha-ha-ha-ha.
Lego Smith's sleep apnea.
Yeah.
He needs a LEGO CFAP machine.
Oh the chickens!
Oh gosh!
That looks mighty close.
Wait, are we gonna have like a...
Oh dang.
Wait.
It would be so funny if they gave us like a little mini game where we're surfing down the river.
We have to avoid rocks and stuff.
The sled section?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, ready for the sound.
I don't think we heard it so bad this time.
Oh, nope.
We completely avoided that section.
Too violent.
Oh!
Man!
He's bald!
Hello!
Okay, I've seen the movie, but if I hadn't, this would be nonsense.
That would make no sense to me.
Also, why the heck was that just sitting there?
Oh,
there's spiders in here.
That special treasure chest was just sitting there.
Oh, the elephant's so cute.
I like how things explode.
It's not something I'm quite over yet.
It's so funny.
They skipped the scene where Willy was being difficult.
They skipped so much.
But you know what?
I'm okay because she's actually tolerable.
Oh, oh!
She's so much more tolerable in this, you know?
Are they okay?
Are they afraid of a shovel?
Why are they?
What's wrong with them?
Oh.
Oops.
Sorry.
I thought I could, um...
Come here, come here, come here.
Alright, let's go.
Chris, we need to pick up Highlight.
Maybe they're afraid of the snakes.
Elephants like to play in the mud.
That's so cute.
Okay, now they can come over.
Or the elephant is gonna stab- Oh!
Oh!
I forgot, Indy's afraid of snakes.
How could I forget?
Um, alright, Miss.
I think short round just died.
Uh-oh.
How did you forget that?
Well, in the context of the game, you know?
I remember in the movies that he's, you know, afraid, but in the game I forgot.
Snakes.
Why did it have to be snakes?
Nice.
Good job.
All right.
We're gonna meet her in a second.
What is this?
Is this a boat?
Wait, where are we driving to?
Oh, just kidding.
Oh, God.
Everybody out of the water!
Is he clapping?
Oh, my God.
I thought why is to control it, no?
Oh, my gosh.
Why is to get on the boat, no?
Or is it...
Maybe only Indy can pilot it.
Nope.
They just...
They just go into the water.
Wait, there it is.
Oh, there's the symbol.
Oh, my God.
I found it!
I got the symbol!
You need the shovel!
Oh gosh, are they okay?
Are they gonna be alright?
Get on!
Oh my god, there's so many alligators!
We're fine, they'll be fine.
Oh!
Wait, they can go on land?
Or I think Short Round has pushed the...
I think they...
I think he has pushed him onto the...
Oh!
That's so silly.
BAM!
I will create and then I will destroy it.
Hey, that's my boat.
Alright, everybody on!
Okay, never mind.
Good luck!
Good luck getting back!
I will create and then I will destroy and then I will create again!
Alright, but we do need them over here because we in a little lagging here.
Oh, wow.
Look at all those snakes!
Wow.
Oh.
The scream button is so funny.
It's actually maybe my favorite thing ever.
Wait, no, no, no.
No.
I want you to scream.
Wait, how do I- oh, there it is.
I push it.
Or I pull it.
Push it.
Pull it.
Pop it.
Okay, Indy, if you're- why did you- why did you come over here if you're gonna be like such a little baby about it, okay?
Go back- I'll see you on the other- just don't even bother.
Just don't even bother.
Short route's gonna kill him.
Pop it.
Twist it.
Beep it.
Boop it.
Yay!
Oh, Indy?
Will you do the honors, please?
What does short round do?
What is it because...
Oh, nothing.
You just sit there looking cute and charming.
Just the little guy he is.
Oh, okay.
Let's ride.
Easy?
Easy peasy.
Oh, what are all these bananas for?
Oh.
Alright, head back here.
Indy, I need you on this side.
Because we still have the shovel, so we can dig this up.
He's short.
I feel like we've had this conversation.
We might have and I just...
You know.
I might have just been like...
I don't know.
What the hell are these?
Oh, I think we need the...
The...
Banana to give to the monkey.
Okay.
Wait.
All right, get banana.
Get banana.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, that was close.
Anyway, oh, he's got the thing.
I could just kick his ass.
Oh, no, I can't.
Ah, it's a spider!
Okay, oh, sorry.
Okay, so she's She's afraid of spiders.
Well, she is afraid of bugs, that makes sense.
Cute!
Um, how do I get the banana?
It wouldn't let me grab it on the...
Maybe Indy can whip it.
Hmm.
Maybe I can whip it...
Ow!
Like, oh.
Well, I'm an elephant, but I need the elephant to come over here.
Or...
Okay, come here.
Oh, nope.
There we go.
Okay, I can't whip while on the elephant.
Oh my gosh, and he killed me.
Um...
Let me try whipping it from this side.
Oh!
Okay.
Wait, there was a target.
Oh, there we go.
Oh my gosh.
This is so messed up.
Whipping real good.
Hey, you want this?
Give me.
You know how many times I died trying to get this?
Nice aim.
Thanks.
I don't care if you're being sarcastic.
I don't think I care.
Wait, elephant, come back?
Oh, here we go.
I'm just gonna go stomp on it.
Holy moly!
Oh.
Okay, um, do we...
Someone said don't forget to shovel, but do we need it?
Did I lose the other one?
Oh, okay.
I literally just found out the answer.
Like, right now I found out the answer.
Like, actually at this moment, I found out the answer.
It was a massacre.
We killed every living creature in this forest.
Yes.
I will become the truest adventurer.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Onwards.
Wait, what's up here?
Nothing.
All right, Indy, I believe in you.
Face your fears.
Okay.
I think that was it.
What have we got going on here?
Alright, everybody, teamwork!
Oh!
Even the elephant knows what to do.
Okay.
Even the elephant cooperates.
Is he stuck down there?
We'll never see him again.
Oh.
That's it!
That's it for our dear friend!
Alright, let's go.
Elephants are very smart.
Wait, is there anything over here?
Secret.
Nothing.
Hello!
I wonder what's on the menu tonight.
it's hot dogs oh my gosh I think there's people in here wait they actually gave him a hot dog
oh we have photographic evidence of you committing crimes no I've never committed a crime I'm too tired good night
Oh no!
Oh yes, thank you for this meal.
Oh no.
Oh my god!
Why are we getting beat up here?
Okay, cool.
What's that sound?
Take that, take that, and move it to somewhere.
Oh, it's that guy.
He's making a bunch of noise.
Let's see.
Over here?
No.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I destroy you and your tables.
And your monkey brains.
And your gauntlet, goblet, goblins, goblets.
Shut up.
Oh, sorry.
Not you, Shorty.
Oops.
I didn't mean it.
I was talking about the bug.
Hello?
There we go.
Wait, why isn't it working?
Not the child!
Guys, I'm struggling.
I think the game...
is silly.
It's missing a gear.
Oh, is it...
this metal gear, perhaps?
Nah.
Oh, the lava crawler.
But what's up there?
What is this thing up here?
How mysterious.
Okay, Indy, you stand here.
It's a new secret.
I want it!
I was gonna have him sit in there and she'd jump on him.
It was my foolproof plan!
Indiana Jones!
Why?
Wait, there's like a big old guy up there too.
Try the fountain.
Fountain?
You guys see a fountain?
It's a parcel for an extra, you can only get it in free play.
Uh...
Boom!
My plan!
My plan was so smart!
Okay.
Onwards.
Guys, is it time for Lego sexual tension?
Oops, bye-bye.
We're gonna go to our rooms, and we're gonna be like, You want me.
No, you Lego want me.
They just drop from the ceilings.
I think they skipped that.
Dang.
We're missing all the best parts.
You Lego want me.
No, you Lego want me.
Never let go of me.
No minus two that.
That was pretty good.
Oh, we need the thuggy, man.
Oh!
I've got it.
in so many this time.
Are you saying they're going to be bricked off?
They're already brixed!
Bricks!
Brick, brick!
It's already happened!
Plus two.
Thank you.
Dang it.
You were talking about me, right?
Oh!
I'm freaking decapitating people.
I'm killing them.
I'm killing them one by one.
Wait, what is this?
This is fancy.
Wait, what are these?
This is so secretive.
They cut out the statue scene.
They cut out the scene where they're in the bedrooms and, like, you know, do them.
Oh.
Sorry.
Sorry, shorty.
I'm shattering glass now!
Oops.
Oh my god, the music.
Wait!
You Lego want me!
Oh my god!
Sorry.
Sorry, Indy.
I got too, way too excited.
We're Lego building the bed!
Indy.
Indiana Jones!
What's this?
Oh, my bad.
She's just screaming.
So we have to figure out- wait, so we built the bed.
Oh, was this so- wait.
Oh, we just destroy it.
Who would have thunk?
But all you have to do is destroy it!
Alright.
Well, of course we can't do any, you know, sexual tension here because we got Shorty.
He doesn't know anything.
He doesn't think about that kind of stuff.
Oh, sorry.
He doesn't even know what a boob is.
And we're gonna keep it that way.
We're gonna keep it that way.
Wait, and we got the book!
Okay.
Alright, read.
Down, middle, right.
Wait.
Down, middle.
I got it.
I only know that word from Drake and Josh.
And so would he.
That's the only way he would know, too.
Kill him!
Till they're dead!
Oh, my bad.
I guess if that's what...
Wait, when it goes back?
Oh.
Wait, is this the sexy statue that they push the boobs in to open the door?
It's all here!
Oh!
You guys remember from the movie!
And she's all embarrassed about having to push in the boobs.
Oh!
That's spooky.
I never watched the movie.
Uh-oh.
Wait, how do we do it, though?
How do we do it, though?
Indy, this is a job for you.
How do I pull?
These games hit different.
What could I possibly be building here?
Oh my gosh, look at the little Lego portrait.
The
bed?
What about the bed?
We already used it to its true purpose.
His purpose was he...
Oh, wait!
Wow, just kidding.
We did not use it to its true purpose.
I thought it was just for the chest, but it is not.
No, they replaced it.
Oh, we gotta build her boobs.
Yeah, see, we built them.
We built them.
They're under there.
Did you see?
Okay.
Oh,
spooky music.
We're a very spooky area.
Oh, sorry.
Wait.
How am I supposed to grab that chest, though?
How the hell did you get over here?
Oops.
It's all up to you, Shorty.
How do you get that?
You gotta...
Wait, maybe...
Indy can dive.
Ha ha!
Yes.
I may be a genius.
I don't remember this place being so...
Big.
Yep.
I don't remember it being this large.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh.
I'm doing something.
Wait, this is for Shorty, right?
I love your hat.
Thank you!
Come, come, come, come, come, come, come, come.
Come, come, come, come, come.
Your services are needed.
Come, come, come, come, come, come.
Oh.
Oh, he got it.
He has to do the other side.
Oh, okay.
Okay, one more time.
Why is my maid so yee-haw today?
Yee-haw!
Oh, and Indy's gotta, okay.
We gotta do it at the same time.
Because we're a team!
There's a whole lot of spatters.
Watch out, ma'am.
I'll get you over here right safe.
I promise you.
Wait.
Oh, here we go.
Uh, wait.
Can we make a path if we throw the fire?
Or is that only the...
Uh, the snakes?
Wait, where'd my...
Wait, where'd it go?
Oh, I'm holding it.
I think.
Here we go.
Oh, no.
This...
Maybe...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come on, friends.
Wait, what happened?
Uh-oh.
Oh.
Okay, I think they need to, um...
No!
My stuff!
I think they need to jump first.
Alright.
jump jump if i jump you die come on jump oh my
god oh my god it's a massacre okay let's just keep going
okay we'll wait for we'll wait for both of them to respawn
all the chests.
Really?
We'll wait for both of them to respawn, so we'll have maximum firepower.
Then I'll throw one in there, and then...
I don't know.
To be honest, am I just stupid?
Throw?
Grab.
Alright.
Let's go, team.
Wait.
Okay, it did make it in here.
Come on.
Stick close.
Oh my gosh!
We did it!
oh my god we did it we did it we just needed the ai to cooperate a little a little bit what the heck i'm finding chests like crazy oh it's is this the room oh is this the room is this the room
a bit of a timer uh anybody could also do something and the game is sabotaging me
whoa go
don't forget your hand
i love that part
wait are we gonna get possessed lego indie lego possessed
Oh my god, Lego sacrificial ritual.
Kalima!
Oh,
he's nice and tanned.
He's fine.
No one dies in Lego.
Let me skip
the heart scene.
It's too...
Wait, prepare for the sound?
It's too- it's too rated R for our little...
E for everyone game.
When I was a kid, this part...
Oh, sorry, I missed it.
Were you saying that that part scared you?
Oh my gosh, we were so close!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
This part is still freaky.
Even as just little Lego guys.
They have the things that we're looking for.
The little breads.
Ah!
Oh!
Okay, she's gone now.
Okay.
Um... Okay.
Wow, there's a lot of guys down there.
Wait, that's not good.
Short round!
Oh my god, you're...
He's going to sacrifice himself!
Why did you do that?
Take this?
Okay, yeah.
No, it's not the last chest because this is a different chapter unfortunately.
Okay, so...
Oh!
Okay, just kidding.
I gotta go this way.
Oh my god!
There's so many guys.
Where are you going?
Nope.
You're dead.
You're done, Zo.
I need you, short round.
I need you.
Um, how can we fix this?
What if I go down?
Because there's also a chest down there.
Oops.
And you die.
Okay, good to know.
There's a lot going on in here.
Okay.
There's so much going on right now.
What is this?
Oh.
So many torches.
For what purpose?
Hmm.
Oh, wait, there's a ladder here.
Oh.
Oh, I'm not hitting a single guy.
I'm not hitting anybody.
Oh, sorry, Shorama.
Dylan, don't get in my way, buddy.
It's dangerous.
It's so dangerous here.
Okay.
What is this?
Let's push it down.
Oh, we're like awfully close to the lava, but like risk it for the biscuit.
Because the money is great.
Okay, we put this over here.
Oh my gosh.
We're like doing actual parkour.
Wait, okay, hold on.
Oh!
This is how we...
Some puzzles can only be completed by pressing Y.
I take control of another character.
Oh, I need him to...
Push this.
Um...
Short round, don't do it!
Oh.
Um...
Wait.
How do we get it back?
Just like that.
And let's put this on here, because I don't think I can...
Alright.
Beam me up!
I don't think I can...
Oh, geez.
Okay, there we go.
Nice.
I don't think I can climb the ladder with it.
That's what I was trying to say.
Okay, aye!
Okay, now we just need the other one.
Oh, where?
Where?
Oh, where do we get it from?
Oh, I have to somehow get him over here.
Wait, what is this?
Wait.
Go downstairs.
Oh, oh my gosh.
Good thing he had a quick hand.
Uh...
Wait.
I thought there would be more ledges than that.
Um...
Okay.
Uh...
My plan was foiled?
Foiled?
It's spoiled again.
Gotta find a way to bring the bridge up.
Yeah!
I'm just trying to...
I don't see it, like...
you bring a bridge up.
Like, knocking it down with, like, all these torches would be...
What if I go down, instead?
Oh, I just...
I got money.
Hmm.
We gotta do the thingy!
Right side is the example.
Wait, what do you mean?
Oh!
Like, with the...
The thing below?
Oh, I see, I see.
You do need the torches.
Wow.
Who designed this?
This design is whack.
Oh my gosh.
That one was the most puzzly puzzle we could have gotten.
Oh.
Oh, you know what?
Actually, yeah, you can bring this down.
You're so strong!
Okay, yeah, let me handle it.
Okay, we're about the same speed.
They give you four torches.
I don't know.
I didn't think about the torches.
I was thinking about everything else.
I got every other puzzle so far I get tripped up on one And you guys are like Damn she's dumb Damn she can't even Look at the torch is stupid God
Oh so close Wait I think if I die I can get it Everybody Hmm
I did not mean to do that.
I like how it's burning in my pants.
Wait, can I get back up here?
Oh, I don't think I can.
Oh, wait, I can.
Oh, take that out and then put that...
Oh, oh, but I can't put it here.
Okay, just kidding.
I thought it might do something.
I don't know.
I was thinking outside the box.
I was thinking...
Man, maybe I came up with something.
Like a little bit of a genius idea.
I don't know.
Oh my gosh.
Take that.
Take the money.
I'll take the money and I'll go around.
There's a thing up there.
It was worth a shot.
I had an idea, an inkling of an idea.
Oh!
Oh, what's wrong with me?
Why did I do that?
Oh, shawati.
Rip money.
My money.
Yeah, I need these to line up again.
All right.
I can't freaking see.
Oh, my gosh.
wish I could move the oh I did it again I wish I could move the camera over just a little bit or like turn it a little bit
I'm just being greedy I don't need it oh my gosh grab it grab it Indy grab it
hey why didn't she get that Come on!
Come on!
Wait, how do I get up from here?
We're holding?
Oh my gosh, the things are not aligning at all.
I don't know if I can reach the rope.
I'll try.
It's worth a shot, I suppose.
Oh!
Oh, I can reach the rock.
Even better.
Actually, though, let's try this rope.
Oh, okay.
Good job.
We're swinging.
We're not swinging.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I couldn't watch the movies until I was older and was this game as my only source of info for seven years.
round was just a very small adult veil you probably would think that yeah
you probably would think that
i also well i never played this game but i did not watch the movies until recently i think you're softlocked because you didn't get to Shut up!
Don't scare me like that!
Don't scare me!
I thought you were serious!
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Alright.
You forgot the shovel for real though.
I don't- I did not see one.
There was many things to dig up and I did not see one.
not see.
Wait, was this area optional?
Wait, huh?
Wait.
One of my kitties, Marilyn, who is notoriously shy, loves to come out when she hears you.
My other guy, Ernie, likes to pretend he doesn't like you.
He might just not like me.
All this for money!
When I've lost so much of our...
much to this area oh my god what is the point oh my god short rounds been on deep end wait he's been he's been going around in circles this whole time
just waiting for me counseling don't there he goes
Oh wait, I forgot I can jump here!
No, I can't.
Oh my gosh, no wait, am I stuck again?
No, no, we'll just go back to the rock.
Go back to the rock, go back to the rock.
Wait!
Okay, ah!
This might be my least favorite puzzle in the game.
Guys, oh, you see, there he is.
I'm joining you!
Okay, that one was my fault for real.
Oh gosh.
Can I just jump from here?
Please!
I have nothing left to lose.
Why did I do that?
Wait, why did I do that?
Okay, we lived, but at what cost?
Oh,
I can't...
Okay.
We're watching your sister before you read a card and you help me through some hard times and get our early birthday song.
Thank you so much, thank you, thank you.
I hope I said your name right.
I've lost thousands.
I've lost, I've lost thousands at this point.
Okay.
I don't know if I can get taller.
I feel like I have to jump here.
These are speedrunner strats.
No stinking way.
What are these?
This is so cute!
Wait, what is this warning?
What is this warning?
me about.
What are all of these, too?
Are these, like, the secret?
No, they would just be treasure chests.
What is this?
Anyway.
Get me out of this hellhole of a room.
I don't want to be here anymore.
What is this down there?
Oh, there's, like, a galt.
What is all this?
I don't care anymore.
I thought that was Kermit.
all your money was part of the speedrun strats.
Oh my god.
Calima.
We're gonna get Lego possessed.
Cat keeps what you have over nap every time you mention short rounds.
I guess it's weird.
Big Rick.
Aw.
Oh.
Yeah!
Kick their butt.
Okay, Indy just went for it.
Wait, does he not get possessed?
Don't we have to save her?
There we go.
He's a genius.
Oh.
Oh, it's one of these types of puzzles.
Okay, so we pull this out so you can hop on top.
Destroy.
for riches and gold and everything your heart could ever desire.
Oh, I gotta get in there.
What the hell is this thing?
Oh, this is my entrance.
I see.
Wait.
Oh, I see.
I see.
He's gotta push it all the way there.
She's dead already.
No, we saw the other guy.
She's just getting a tan.
She's just getting a...
Come on, Indy.
Poor Aisha.
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay, nice.
We'll try later.
The music is so mysterious.
Oh!
Are those her booty cheeks or...
Whoa!
Wait.
Can I- What?
Wait, what just happened?
That thing just moved to me!
What the heck?
Is that why it's saying no?
Because we're not the character that we need to be?
Hmm.
I love how short round it's just doing everything.
Oh, they're just not impressed.
That don't impress me much.
Oh, oh, oh.
I wish I could get another heart.
Oops.
Okay, Indy, it's your turn.
Grab it, grab it, grab it!
They were not impressed.
Wait, but there's so much going on.
Come on in here.
Oh.
Oops.
Don't worry about it.
Oh.
Oh, oh, come on.
How did we live before?
We got our money back.
Nice!
We lived?
We lived!
Um...
Oh, I forgot to press...
I forgot to pull the lever, didn't I?
Did I pull the lever?
I don't think I did.
Oopsie.
There we go.
We'll like actually save her?
Instead of being greedy?
Hiya!
What's happening?
Oh my god!
Who are you?
Wait, who are you?
Oh, you're the...
You're a boss.
Holy moly.
You're set.
Yeah!
Kick his butt!
Kick his butt short round!
Wait, I need that heart.
I got a new hat.
Oh my god.
What a... Oh!
Oh my gosh, he's so annoying.
Wait, he's so annoying.
Wait, Indy, I need you to do stuff.
Oh my god, wait!
I need a gun!
Someone give me a gun!
Try the statue now.
Hi!
Wait, what just happened?
Wait, the statue worked.
He's like, ow!
Aie!
Oh, my God.
Oh, are you okay?
My sweet madam.
Guys only want one thing.
What the?
Wow.
Calims
and treasure to take back to the museum.
Tiny bread.
Tiny Lego bread!
Wait, let me see.
How far are we in this one?
What was that?
Chapter 3?
Yes.
So now we have four.
So there's what?
There's six for each one?
I feel like we're zooming through it this time just because I'm not taking every second to go around.
Last time I went and explored everywhere, you know?
This time, I'm actually playing the game, believe it or not.
Enemy Boxer!
Is there a Common Rider episode today?
No, Common Rider episodes are Saturday, if you're like, US time, and Sunday morning, if Saturday night, and Sunday morning, um...
Oops.
I don't know.
Oh, wait, I have money for him.
For, like, Like, JST.
Is that the guy that gets sliced by the propeller?
It is!
Oh, look, there's the little mailbox thing.
Oh my gosh, the way she walks.
Look at the way...
Damn, that girl.
Her body.
Body, yaddy, yaddy, yaddy.
It's like an optical illusion or something.
It's kind of insane.
Damn, girl, that body of yours is insane.
actually.
Oh, I gotta break something.
Oh yeah, I forgot that you can hide in these.
Same as idle pre-cure.
There you go.
Idle pre-cure.
Same time.
Did I get...
Sorry, I don't mean Deion.
Did I get like all the...
Did I have enough money to buy all the other extras?
Are we just buying people now?
We're freeing the little children!
The child slaves!
Little did we know this...
This is outer heaven.
Wowza!
Wowee!
Alright.
Well, um...
Children!
Any children in here?
I mean, I'm here to rescue you.
Where are you guys?
I'm gonna become a true adventurer by collecting all this money, money, money.
I'm also destroying their stuff so that they can't build anymore.
No more mining and crafting for you.
This is what Lego thinks of Minecraft.
They're like, two are...
dealer idea?
Hoo-ha!
Well, we won't let you get away with it!
Alright, we need a woman's touch.
Too bad they skipped Brainwashed Indy, but he was Brainwashed Hal again yesterday.
Oh,
why is my game freezing all of a sudden?
Guys, why is my game freezing all of a sudden?
That was weird.
Oh, God, please.
The worst part is the scream is like so terrible.
It's like, it doesn't even sound cute.
It's just so awful.
It's so funny.
Oh, no, no, no, no!
No, my- Nice.
Wait, where is...
Where is Shorty?
Why did we lose him?
Oh.
One second.
Oh my gosh, it did not see that.
Like I know in the movie he's gone, but I don't think I saw a cutscene where he left.
Was it?
Was it in a cutscene?
Did I just miss it?
Was I not paying attention?
Was I being in a silly Willy?
Random Willy screams.
I wish it like, I wish it like blinded, not blinded.
Wait, the screams that make you go blind.
I wish it deafened them.
I think that'd be pretty funny.
Hey, leave me alone.
They keep sliding down!
Oh my gosh, it's like a never-ending hole.
Stop!
Oh, sorry, Endy.
I didn't mean to.
Okay, we finally made it.
Oh.
You gotta say, what did I do?
Very nice.
Oh, my bad.
I'm always kicking his butt.
Ah!
We need you, Shorty.
We need you.
Wait, that's a child!
Oh my god, the children can crawl!
Why did he just have to take off his hat for that?
The children can crawl!
They have capabilities!
I...
I'm not gonna lie, guys.
I've... I haven't stopped thinking about the Minecraft movie.
It's just...
Why was it the way that it was?
Okay.
Ah, here we go.
Oh, is it gonna be like, hello?
Okay, there we go.
Celebration of my birthday, please take my money!
No!
Chinetics, thank you!
Happy birthday!
Congrats on the upcoming 3D debut!
We're nearly birthday buddies!
Wait.
I don't put this here?
Okay, we got this.
Easy as...
Oh my gosh, this is just like getting the ration in Metal Gear.
First try!
It's just the exact same.
Am I gonna be able to make this jump?
Oh, no.
Wait.
Uh-oh.
Guys?
Wait, how...
Is it fine, is it?
Oh, she just knocked me down.
Yeah, you deserve that, Willy.
Into the...
Oh, did it just go into the lava?
Wait, what was it, though?
I don't even know what I got.
What is this?
Oh, it's out of trouble.
Maybe there's one in here.
Wait, there's gotta be one in here.
Yes.
Just drop into the lava for it to respawn.
I will do that.
But where does it go?
It's so mysterious.
Unless it goes like here?
Oh.
Instead, I fall into the lava.
I must do it!
No, Frodo!
I'll throw the ring into the fire!
Um, oh, thank goodness it's back.
Wait, but what do I do with this still?
Wait, that didn't solve my problem?
Wait!
That didn't solve my problem at all.
I press ass.
I thought it would go right here.
I have no idea I'll be honest there has we have to be able to do something with this no could
you grab it with the whip oh like okay oh I think I get I get what you guys are saying so if I put it on here and then I whip it whip it good
ah and then I put it here oh no then I whip it.
Oh my gosh, you guys are geniuses.
And then I whip it.
Aha!
Oh my gosh, I'm not the genius.
You guys came up with that.
I didn't do that at all.
Okay, now we gotta fix it.
But we gotta shovel, not a wrench.
Oh wait.
No, no.
Turn this.
When will you nai-nai?
Um...
It really, like, depends if I'm on the mood for it.
Uh-oh.
I created my own prison.
First, I whip it.
Ha-ha!
Ha-ha, you are not needed.
Oh, no!
Aw.
Oh.
Oh my god, a child!
I'm not touching the controller.
The stick drift is real.
Please.
Oh, that's... I did this before.
That's right.
Ah!
Why would you do this to me?
Oh, are they gonna be non-stop?
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
I'm gonna ignore them.
Please jump.
Jump in the...
There we go.
No, please.
Oh, I missed one.
Little child!
Give me the money in there!
Give me the...
Oh, I thought there was something else in there, to be honest.
Okay, never mind.
We can keep going.
Oh!
They're also gonna keep going.
We need this.
And we're gonna throw it at that.
Could have thrown it at you, buddy.
Hey, you could have been the one to receive that bomb.
What's this do?
Oh, what is this?
Break rock.
I always do.
Oh, it goes here.
Like this.
Oh.
Wait, what's this dude?
What did I get?
Oh, nothing?
All right, lady.
Oops.
Ha-ya!
Ha-ha!
Oh, I did it.
Somebody raised.
Thank you so much.
I didn't see you.
I'm so sorry.
Thank you.
Hello.
The Indiana Jones!
Look at us, look at us kill people!
But it's like, we're saving, we're saving the slaves!
Child soldiers!
It's all just another day in the Indiana Jones way.
Don't worry about it.
Where does this go?
Well, we have a hat and an explosive.
Ducky, thanks for the gift, Dad.
T-Cup.
T-Cup, did you get?
Did you get Nozomi and Hikari in Blue Archive?
Guys, it's kind of crazy.
Okay, I've done several hundred, not several hundred.
I've done maybe 150 pulls now.
I haven't gotten either of them.
But, but, I did get four?
I did get four new...
three star girls in Blue Archive that I did not have before
which is kind of crazy so I didn't get the new girls but I did get other people that I didn't have yet what is this?
where does this go?
what did I get?
I got Kiyadata, I got uh finally.
Oh my gosh.
I got regular and I got someone else and I can't remember right now.
I got both under 60 rolls.
I'm gonna kill you.
That's a real threat.
Why is my Gacha Lux so bad, man?
Hina and her purple dress.
I already have that.
But you can only get her.
You can only get her.
She's a unique for characters, so you can't get her all the time.
Stop!
Nice!
Wow!
That was easy.
Oh my god, look how many children there are in here!
Oh, dig, dig, dig.
What is this?
This go- oh, oh, release the children!
Whoa, one second, children.
Hold on, Mama's gotta be greedy real quick.
Come on, children.
You can wait.
You've been in there for long enough, okay?
Wait, what is...
Oh!
Wait, are these bouncy?
No.
I didn't think so.
I was like, they're wood.
I heard if you do gotcha while your OBS is open, your luck might boost.
Source Green Women.
Really?
So if I do a pull right now, I could do two 10 pulls right now.
With my OBS open.
Wait, what's on the other side?
I guess it doesn't matter.
But you gotta show us.
I can't because it's all on my phone.
I'm sorry.
Don't know.
Don't just scream.
What do I take this to?
You wouldn't hurt a lady.
Was you?
Did I just get him in the garage?
Is that where she just held that area?
Oh, sorry, Indy.
Okay, let's do the same thing we did before.
Willie has other ideas.
No, no, no.
You need to stream your pulls to get streamer gotcha luck.
It's on my phone.
I don't know what to tell you guys.
Then you'll never see that I won't do a 10 pull.
Why did it bounce?
I don't know.
Oh, that kid's crying.
No, he's fine.
He's smiling.
Yeah, I got games on your phone.
Indy, I'm going to murder you.
I'm going to murder you.
Move!
It's on Steam, too.
Yeah, I know.
But I, um...
way why did it do that why did it do that anyway i was saying i know blue blue archive is also on steam maybe it'll work now but um it like crashed my computer last time i tried so um that was when it like first came out though so who knows it might be better now i don't think i'm doing this correctly okay um Let's see if there's another way to do this,
maybe.
Surely there's something else to do here.
Oops, I...
Maybe I don't do this at all.
Wait, what's that for?
Is it for this kid?
Oh, I don't think so.
I think you can just jump with it.
You think so?
Oh wait, I need jail.
Oh, where?
But it doesn't go there anyway.
Something for below.
Maybe?
Dusty, thank you so much.
For the vibe, get the thank you.
Oh my god, shut the hell up, please.
Oh my gosh, we were totally overthinking it.
For me.
I was overthinking it.
That's it!
That's all it did was explode?
We used the machine just for it to explode?
It's faulty, it's faulty.
Alright, we can keep going.
See you later, kid!
Quit your crying.
I'm gonna name you Ryan.
Crying Ryan.
Shorty!
This is a boss fight?
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, no.
He's gonna do the voodoo.
Or...
Wait, what is this?
I don't remember this.
Uh...
Oops.
Stop chasing after me, you freak.
Oh.
My goodness.
We had to throw it at him, I bet.
I don't throw it at that kid?
Oh, I blew myself up on accident.
Oopsie.
I did blew myself up again.
I done blow myself up.
Oh my god, please.
Oh, and he keeps getting healed.
Ah, let's see.
figure out what to do i really am um oh do i push this into something
maybe if i don't oh no it doesn't work he even gets healed all the way from over here
yeah even from all the way over here oh yeah the bars where are the box one was short short round and then There are no bars.
Come on.
Oh, what's down here?
Whole lot of nothing.
They're not even fighting.
Come on, you guys need me.
This is AFK.
Oh my god.
So funny.
Um...
Where is this dude though?
I don't think it breaks that.
I think it's just used here to jump as a platform.
Oh, we can't get up there.
I don't...
I feel like I need to kill the kid, but I can't...
They put aside their differences.
Oh, wait.
Look at this thing right here in the front is where they, like, do the...
The fist fighting part.
Oh, wait.
Can I break him out?
Aha!
Okay, okay.
Oops, I killed him at the same time, but that's...
You know...
sacrifices must be made.
There we go.
No, no, no.
Keep going.
Oh, I... Oh.
Oh, he can use the tunnel, but I may not.
That's fine, I suppose.
Oh.
Wait, did it work?
The royal tunnel.
Use it.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Thank goodness.
This guy.
I'm gonna murder you.
It's a good thing we already, uh...
It's a good thing we already pushed this thing over, huh?
Hindsight.
Ouch!
Oh my god, how did he get this?
How did he get that?
Oh, I have to go through everything!
I don't know why I waited, but it's whatever.
Oh!
Yeah.
his lights out!
Oh.
We're friends now.
Oh,
wait.
It's time.
Wait.
Who's doing this?
Wait, what are we doing?
Wait, what's happening?
Are they not gonna fight?
Oh, my God!
Holy moly!
I thought they were gonna fight in there.
Can we blow up now?
The Lego boulders.
Oh, come on!
I should have cheesed.
What do they want me to do here now?
Need some more hearts.
Yay!
I'm a little stupid, I think.
Oh, wait.
There's stuff down here.
Maybe we get him from down here.
Let's see.
I'm just stupid.
Yeah, this is where he gets crushed.
Yeah, but now I'm just like they don't want me to do that, so I'm kind of wondering what they want me to do, you know?
I don't quite know what they want me to do instead.
You got this, Vito?
Thanks!
Yeah, I'm not quite sure what they're like.
They're like, you can't!
You can't fight him you can't fist fight him on there so what am i supposed to like parry the the boulder back at him i tried oh oops oh my gosh it does what me okay i just need it to oh oh are you kidding me that's so unfortunate okay hold on i think when he has the boulder
Okay, when he carries the boulder.
What?
Why is his aim?
Okay, why is your aim so bad?
Huh, kids?
Come on, this is a life or death situation.
Okay, that, okay, maybe I do actually parry the boulder.
Maybe I do parry the boulder.
Okay, no.
Because the target goes away as soon as that...
As he throws it, the target goes away.
Do I really have to go all the way below?
Because there's only two places.
Oh my gosh, this is so annoying then.
I was hoping that wasn't the case.
Am
I just overthinking it or is it just actually obtuse?
Oh my god, I have to time...
There's no way that you have to time it perfectly to win...
to grabbing the...
when he has the boulder.
Parry it with a whip?
I mean, I could try, but I don't think so.
There's some obtuse stuff in this game.
Is there?
Wow, I was able to...
Well, I think it actually just bounced off my head.
I think it just... I don't think I parried it.
I think it bounced off my head.
We got it!
We got the timing!
Okay.
Oh wow, okay.
That's kind of...
Okay.
Ouch!
Oh gosh.
Please!
No!
Oh, the timing is terrible.
Wait, oh my gosh, I have to hope that it loads in time.
Okay, please, please load!
Please!
Please load!
I missed it.
I missed opportunity!
Oh my god.
Okay, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Come on, load.
Thank you.
Okay, nice, nice.
Just one more.
He
already saw!
He already saw!
Ah, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Grab his nipple.
to punish him.
Yay!
Oh, it took so long.
Oops.
We didn't hear the sound.
Sorry.
It's, what is it called?
The Purple Nerf Pull.
Right?
Did he grab it?
Yeah.
He took his hat.
And you take his nipple.
Equivalent exchange!
Oh my goodness.
Oh my god, oh my god!
It's just death!
It's just carnage!
Alright, let's get out of here, folks.
Escape the mines.
What's this?
Why is it so shiny?
Why are you?
Oh!
Oh, wait, can I blow it up?
Oh, this is one of my favorite levels.
I'm excited.
Do we actually get to play in the minecart?
I really want to.
I've always thought that the minecart part would be such a great, like, attraction at a theme park, you know?
And if we are getting a new Indiana Jones ride, this is their chance to make it different from the previous two.
Sorry, I need to stop talking about the rides.
It's my special interest and I won't shut up.
Where does this go?
Oh, here.
Oh,
okay.
Gotta fix the cart.
Disney's lazy, though.
There's no way that they'll make an entirely new ride.
As much as I'd wish for it to happen.
There's absolutely no way.
Don't do it.
Don't jump off.
Yeah, there you go.
Don't do it.
So it's just true.
She was like, I might do it.
Oh wait, I need Indy up here.
Oh my god.
She said I might do it.
Okay.
Whoa.
Interesting.
Okay.
Oh, I didn't mean to grab that actually.
I meant to try and get up here.
There we go.
What is this now?
How do we turn it from red to green?
The sound effects in this game are so good.
They're so fun.
They really are.
What am I missing?
Oh!
I can't!
Wait, who?
Oh, I just killed him.
I just killed him.
The minecart has a handle.
Oh, it does?
I missed it.
Thank you.
Ah, you're right.
Let the kid do all the work.
Wait, is it gonna move?
No.
But they'll tip us for it.
our... for our attempt.
Trying to... I've been trying to...
I noticed that the railing was not complete.
I was trying to figure out what would be the way to fix the track.
But I cannot figure out.
Is there anything else to explode?
I do not see.
I don't...
I
love the shiny spot.
Is there another one?
There's another shiny?
No.
Some boxes right next to the rail.
Did I just not...
Oh my gosh.
I didn't do my Minecraft duty.
I mean, my Lego duty.
It's basically Minecraft.
This one.
Okay!
Push it along.
Give us tiny little legs.
Block game duties.
Alright, team.
Everybody up?
Oh, gosh.
Will you go first?
No, no, no.
Don't over there.
Over here.
Okay, team.
We need to all be up here.
Now we go to the other side.
Okay, team.
It'll blink green.
It'll say, this is a mine cart.
Oh, it does.
It said, it said.
Where did the second one come from?
You need to do this to, okay, okay.
Who am I?
Okay, I'm Indy.
Was I supposed to hit that?
Oh, was I supposed to hit that?
Is I supposed to hit that?
Oh!
Line up to...
I got that!
Okay, wait.
We're gonna do this.
We'll do this.
Surely?
Wait.
Wait, I'm pressing the button though.
Oh, maybe I need to hit it with the... Okay.
Ah, okay, okay, okay.
I was doing the wrong button.
That's my bad.
Ah, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick.
Oh, I have to...
Bing, oh, Bing.
Bing, bong.
Bing.
Who's next?
Oh.
Bing.
Okay, and one more on this side.
Easy peasy.
Bing.
Bing bong.
Oh.
This is so fun.
Bing!
I hit something.
Oh, oh, that one's lucky.
Oh, oops, I didn't realize that was the wrong one.
I'm just flailing around.
Lucky, lucky, lucky.
Okay, one more.
It's so funny.
Oh, oopsie.
My bad.
Oh!
Ah!
I missed it again!
It's at the very end.
Oh my gosh.
Bink, bink!
Oh, oops.
My bad.
Okay.
It's on the right.
Yeah.
Okay.
Holy cow.
Oh.
Dang it.
I'm a sec.
Oh.
I did it!
The water!
They're gonna flood us out!
Uh-oh, we can't make any more mistakes.
Oh, just kidding.
We can't make mistakes.
Oh!
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da Alright, just two more, right?
Why is it invisible?
I feel like I was pretty thorough about our coins, but I guess not.
Oh, hot, hot, hot, hot, hot, hot.
Wait, oh, I think we need to run.
Wait, this is actually coming towards us.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, wait, I'm stuck.
Ah!
Nice!
First try.
Oh my gosh.
I didn't think it was actually coming towards us.
I don't know what I thought.
I don't
know what I thought.
I
guess just that...
I don't know.
So funny.
Oh, okay, we have to stay on the side.
Alrighty.
We'll swing a little bit and...
Whee!
Yuppa!
Can I jump here?
I see a secret.
I see a secret big guy.
That's worth a lot.
Let me up.
Thank you.
That was close.
Up and away!
Okay.
I'm not quite sure.
Here, though.
What do you guys got going on over here?
Let's check you guys.
Maybe you guys have something on your side that'll help me.
Oh, they probably have something that'll pull out that, um...
Oh, see, see?
Aha!
Like this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait.
What is this?
Oh, it's for here.
Sarzangel.
What is it?
Two...
To the one family, you guys are sabotaging me for real.
Two hearts, one, watch out.
One family.
I don't think, I don't know if I've ever seen Tarzan.
Not sure.
Yeah, I think I just remember it from Kingdom Hearts, but I don't know if I've actually watched the movie.
But I think Jane is really pretty.
That's her name, right?
She's, like, so pretty.
You're sitting bits and pieces!
I'm in pieces!
My chest was just hanging out.
Are these also traps?
Maybe not?
Okay.
Oh, my gosh.
Trying to avoid them.
Oh, I need to beat them up.
Stealth 100.
They had no clue.
Oh, we can't go up.
There's no purpose up there.
A shovel!
Perfect.
Oh, this is quite the puzzle.
What is all of this?
Wait, don't I have one more level after this too?
I thought this would be the last level.
It makes more sense, no?
Oh.
I don't quite understand what else they could do.
Oops.
Bye, bud.
Oh, this is the last one.
I feel like it would be.
I feel like there's no reason to go beyond.
Okay, never mind.
This is also a bus.
Oh, my God.
Enough.
We're teaching him how to kill young.
Why are there so many of these guys?
I can't do anything with them.
They hate me.
Unless it's like before where if I put on the hat, they only care about me once I put on the hat.
Hey, this is a priceless artifact!
I think I do, because it drops.
Oh, maybe not.
What do I do with this?
Um, anybody thirsty?
I got a cuppa.
Okay, I'm just gonna leave out there for now.
No one cared about who I was until I put...
Exactly, until I put on the hide.
Sorry.
Someone got in my throat.
What?
Does it want the bush?
No.
Wait, I need my shovel?
Oh, watch out.
Watch out, fam.
Watch out, everybody.
Oh, God, not around here.
I think...
I feel like the...
The cup...
Court is the same colors.
But...
Oh, hello.
But I just don't know where it goes.
Oh, wait.
Maybe it's heavy enough that it goes on top of that.
Oh, my God.
They're incessant.
You guys just don't quit.
Leave me alone.
Pick up the hat.
I will.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait.
You're so impatient.
I was doing one puzzle first.
Let me play the game.
Turn to a little power pot.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
You like my hat?
Yes!
Okay, we got one.
Oh, but what's his...
Oh, everybody needs to wear the hat.
You put on the hat next.
Oops, my bad.
Put on the hat.
Nope, never mind.
Wait, can I have him take off the hat?
I don't think so.
I think we have to wait for them to come back.
And then she puts on the hat.
Everybody gets their turn.
It becomes a Mousseau game.
It feels like it, right?
Oh, sorry.
Someone's hat.
Oh, there we go, nice.
Okay, put on the hat.
All right, and go!
Perfect.
And now?
Shorty.
I didn't realize that something dropped before.
Oh!
They're all patiently waiting?
Wait.
Why are they so...
Why are they all waiting?
Wait, why are they all waiting?
They might be bugged.
They're curious too, yeah, obviously.
That was so strange!
Oh, hat.
Okay, nice.
Now crawl.
Crawl.
It's because I'm wearing their hat!
Okay.
They feel like we're brothers now.
So cute.
I don't know how I missed the first thing that came out here.
Oh, nah, they're still fighting down there.
Hey!
Fine.
Okay, be very, very careful here.
Indy?
Oh.
Stop losing our money, please.
Oh, no.
That was not me.
And then I still got, I still, they get, I took the blame.
She can jump.
Yes.
It's better to just stick with her and then let the boys handle themselves.
Okay, we're fine.
Let the go with the person that's the best at jumping and then...
It's me.
I'm the one best at jumping.
What are we doing here?
Oh.
Just that.
Oh, we gotta get to the other side.
No way.
Okay.
No, no.
Okay, we're fine.
Yes!
We're too good at...
Oh, yes, yes, yes.
We're too good at the... Indy.
Too good at the game!
We're too good at the game!
Oh, it's so cute!
Indy, get out of the way.
Oh, sorry.
What are these?
Making flowers.
Yeah, they're so cute.
Oh!
Big money.
Oh.
This is all you!
That's like a little smiley face.
Oh, okay.
That works.
And...
Some puzzles can only be completed after...
Okay, yeah.
Oh, okay.
You there.
Oh!
Alright, all you, Indy?
He's just gonna let them hang.
He's hanging.
Leaving them hanging!
I grew up watching Indiana Jones movies that are special to me.
Thank you for playing this classic game.
It's so fun to see it again.
I'm sorry, my voice is a little.
Come on.
I'm gonna drink some water.
Your playthrough of Snake Eater is so cool.
Thank you.
Thanks for dropping by, too.
I appreciate it.
Go, go, go.
Oh, my God.
I'm not gonna make it.
I'm not.
Oh, I'm killing everybody.
but the people we need to kill.
Oh my god!
Wait.
Oh my god, there he is.
What did I just do?
Yes.
Oh, they do respawn.
Wait, how the hell am I supposed to kill him?
He robbed me blind.
Come on, I'm trying to...
Oh, can I go up here?
No.
I feel like it has something... Oh my gosh, I'm trapped in there.
Something to do with those, but I don't know.
Like, we have to...
Oh my god.
The music is so loud, I can't even think.
We have to make the bridge burn.
Remember, we have to make the bridge fall.
Oh!
Did I get that?
Come on.
Come on, Indy.
Does he drop it?
Oh, hey, he did.
He did.
Okay.
And then...
Why am I moonwalking?
Ah!
I'm trying to grab the weapon.
Please.
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
Okay.
We'll go over here first.
Why doesn't he use it?
What?
I'm like, I'm going bonkers.
Wait, I grabbed it though.
I did.
Okay, I used it that time, but...
Wait, what the hell?
But it doesn't allow me to aim for the thing, so I'm not quite sure how to knock them down, you know?
I'm so...
Why, game?
Why?
Why do you do this to me?
What the heck, eh?
I think you need a sword.
But nobody is coming with swords.
I'm just losing money after money after money.
Oh my god, my eyes are literally glazing over.
I don't know why.
Whoops, I...
Why I would have to...
Like, who would do something?
Oops, oh my bad.
Is there somebody out?
Oh, okay, he just killed me.
Didn't one of them drop a sword?
No?
Literally every single guy that comes out does not have a sword.
Oh my god.
Meow!
Oh, he didn't kill him.
Wow.
Oh my goodness.
I don't think the boss...
I think we gotta do something with the bridge, just like in the movie.
I don't think it's...
That we use it on the boss.
I think that's what it...
Because the bridge needs to drop.
Just like in the movie, I think.
Yeah.
I think you have to shoot it while the boss is on the bridge.
Okay, we'll try that.
We'll try that.
I have to get a new one.
Let's try that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That seems like it could be right.
If I can aim for it.
Aim?
Nope.
Maybe I...
Oh!
I did not aim for it.
It did not, like, lock on.
Oh my gosh.
I hate these crossbows.
I'm trying to get it.
I'm trying to get it!
Oh, if you swap the characters and he force grabs you, it stops it.
That's cool.
But that doesn't help me.
He's vulnerable.
Oh, when he grabs you.
Okay, okay.
Oops.
I didn't think he would actually, like, destroy me like that.
Okay, so we just gotta, kind of, like, run away from him until he...
Oh, my goodness.
What the heck is happening?
I'm tired of this.
No!
I Dark Souls dodge you!
Oh, I'm trapped.
Oh my gosh.
Indeed!
Why'd you do that?
Oh my gosh.
When the boss jumps on you, starts punching as soon as possible.
When he freezes, you change characters.
Okay.
Thank you!
The game, because like...
Oh, um...
The game, because it like follows the movie, but not really, it's like so...
It becomes so like, wait, what am I supposed to do?
You know what I mean?
What the hell?
He one-shotted me!
You're just like, oh, I know what to do.
I have to take down the bridge!
And then the game is like, no, no.
You have to punch him until he takes control of you, and then he hit him.
I got him!
I got one heart!
Yeah!
Oh.
Hitting everybody, but who we need to?
Where is he?
Where's our buddy?
Is he coming?
Oh, okay.
He's not coming.
I didn't feel like it this time.
Uh, hello?
Why didn't he show up?
Wait, maybe now I actually have to...
Oh wait, because the things are gone.
Hold on.
What is there to grab?
Wait, is that a sword?
Wait, I can't see.
Oh, I think we have to...
Okay.
No way.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, there's a sword!
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
He has a sword.
Now I can grab it.
Where is it?
Okay, he didn't drop it.
I hate this area.
Please, can we not...
Like, I can't see anything over there.
Can we not...
Fight them, please.
Can we just stop fighting?
Can we all just get along?
I don't think they're ever gonna drop a sword again.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Okay, now we have to wait until he comes back!
You bastard!
You're such an asshole.
the same thing every time so it's so annoying okay but we got consistent swords
let me let me take down a heart please oh oh dang it i missed my chance i didn't realize
okay come on hi oh
Oh, this fight sucks.
This fight sucks so bad.
Okay, wait.
No, I didn't hit him.
I did it.
Okay.
Thank God.
We did it.
Oops.
Drop your sword.
Awesome.
No, grab it.
Grab it.
No, please grab it.
I was about to...
That was me.
I was about to start screaming.
Okay.
We're full hearts?
Yeah!
Actually, I'm gonna switch to somebody who doesn't scream.
And like, actually...
Can pick up the sword when needed.
Come on, team!
Did they drop it?
No.
Come on, team!
Did
they drop it?
No?
Come on, team!
This game is easier with two players, I believe that.
Wait...
It looked like he dropped it for a second, but I guess not.
Come on, team!
We're almost there!
Yeah!
Oh my god.
They're coming from all angles now.
They're coming from all angles now!
Holy cow!
Oh my gosh!
They just don't stop coming!
Let me like get back over here.
Oh, grab that heart.
Thank you.
We need that for sure.
Oh, sorry, Indy.
Oh my god, wait.
When does he come back?
Wait, when does he come back?
Unless the... unless he doesn't?
Oh, he doesn't!
No, no, take it out and throw.
Oops, sorry, Indy.
I didn't realize it was just to break the bridge.
We did it.
No way, they took his hair.
She doesn't have any cool tricks.
She's too pretty.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
We did it!
Oh, once I understood the battle, it was better.
It's still silly.
We're fine, though.
Everything's good.
Bye.
Take your bread.
Flowers!
And then they just stared lovingly into each other's eyes, and then she was never heard from again.
My eyes are hurting from staring so much.
Hold on.
I don't think I have any eyedrops in here, though.
See you never, Willy.
Yep.
We never heard from her again.
Yahoo!
Okay.
Oops, sorry.
That was my water bottle hitting.
The...
My mic.
We just keep...
Keep on buying people.
Chin!
Dancing, girl.
Oh, look, we're buying people from the movie we just did, too, so...
Are the other movies?
Oh, yeah, they're locked still.
But we're making enough money that we...
Oh, my gosh, we've almost got everybody.
Nice.
I think we'll definitely be able to...
To buy them all.
Who the hell are you?
But
this was fun!
Thank you guys for the temple of doom!
And then next time, we'll finish it off with the last crusade.
With our papa.
Shhh.
And then we'll be done with Lego Indiana Jones.
Yay!
Yay, yay, yay, yay, yay.
Yeah!
Whoa!
It helps this time I got all my exploration of this place out of the way previously, so we were still able to be at least the last of the arc.
And then...
Yeah!
And
then maybe I can first watch Star Wars and then I could do...
Well, I could do Lego Batman and then I can watch Star Wars.
and then do lego star wars and we'll complete the lego trilogy but i'm sleepy now so i'm gonna take off otsu otsumita everybody thank you so much for look at her look at her emo oh yes queen i have i have to get up early because i have a oh thank you for the mystery thank you for the peek!
Wait, Birlin, I didn't get to see what you said.
I saw something about Blue Archive.
Like, no zombie in, but...
Sorry, but this game, I can't, like, read very well.
But...
Yeah, I have to wake up early tomorrow, so I'm gonna go get some rest.
I have some other stuff I need to finish up too, but thank you guys so, so, so, so much, so I go, thank you!
And I will see you guys when I see you It's all good, sorry.
When I see you next...
Oh my gosh, wait, it looks like he's got a tomato.
Yummy.
I'm gonna go eat a tomato.
Osamito!
Bye-bye!
Thank you, everybody.
Bye-bye, bye-bye.
Bye-bye.
Thank you.